[Music]
you're just
that's what i know
[Music]
uh always glad to have uh this gentleman
on the program
we did them as a special i think last
year two years ago last year
and i was in my my softies my ranger
panties uncle sam that's right um
you know patriotic people always ask
celebrities
or sometimes me they ask do you have
regrets and people like no regrets
that's a regret yeah i have plenty of
regrets
i don't understand like i have no
regrets you've lived a dummy's life
if you have no regrets yes too safe and
you're dumb now
if you have no regrets so uh that being
said i always love
learning from you you'll probably not
hear me talking a whole lot aside from
asking questions
because he is like uh the computer wore
expensive artifacts for shoes uh he
founded
wallbuilders.com uh well he founded
wallbuilders but wallbuilders.com is
where you can go and learn about it he
has all kinds of i don't know what the
value is
of the historical artifacts that he has
there but you probably know who it is
mr david barton how are you sir doing
well steve good to be with you man
i'm glad to be with you do you have a
number on or am i letting the cat out of
the bag i don't want to turn you into a
target the value
of i would imagine that your your little
bunker's like
it's about on par with the hope diamond
yeah it it is
the problem is the value is changing all
the time we're we're adding new stuff
just added a bunch of space collection
stuff from moon walkers and various
things so
we've got some of everything uh actually
there's there's three of us
collaborating on the collection and we
we just picked up darth vader's except
the original
77 darth vader we picked up r2d2
we got the ruby red slippers from
dorothy and wizard of oz
so there's all sorts of little things
that keep getting added and growing and
growing you got the slippers
gay people are going to be furious
because they love judy garland
and probably not your uh your
demographic but
wow that is incredible that you have all
of those things and is it like a comic
book about like where i
you know it's it's worth ten thousand
dollars and then if i breathe on it it's
worth
a buck twenty five because when i was
there you were handing them to me
remember how nervous i was like don't
don't don't give it to me because i'm
clumsy yeah
some of the stuff you really got to be
really delicate with but it's
interesting the older stuff
is a lot more durable and you can handle
a letter of george washington
much more than i can handle a letter
woodrow wilson or fdr because that stuff
it crumbles falls apart they have a lot
of acid in the paper in that time they
didn't know what it did
but back in the original founding era
they made all the papers a lot of linen
in it it was just it was
totally different world did you say they
had a they have a lot of ash in the
paper with woodrow wilson
acid oh acid said yeah wow
a lot of why is that not not the same
not the 60s and 70s asset
it's different from 60 70. i'm going to
learn and
um yeah it goes through your fingertips
um why is that
why is it that something older obviously
we know the composition has more acid
but why did paper
uh start including more acid well they
found faster
faster ways to make paper and cheaper
ways to make paper but the way they did
it
it involved components that that had an
acid base
and even today you can buy novel books
that have an acid-base paper it's going
to last about 20 years it's going to
fall apart in your shell
or you can get more like the academic
books are going to
last like 100 years because it's a
different kind of paper a lot more
expensive that's why you pay 100 bucks
for a school book
and you pay four bucks for a novel it's
a paper in it so
about 30 years down the line if there's
some kind of a nuclear holocaust
huck finn will be a distant memory but
uh gender theory at schenectady
community college it'll last forever
it's the gift that keeps on giving
um let me let me ask you this i have so
much i want to ask
maybe like to go back since you talked
about that to hemp and ropes for ships
because that's something
that's always interesting to me why we
switched over and the cotton trade but
um
obviously fourth of july uh it's a time
where a lot of people are
obviously enjoying the fruits of this
country this wonderful country but a lot
of people
aren't necessarily aware of
exactly how it was founded why it was
founded something that comes up a lot
i've talked about it on my show but i
know you're an expert
is the idea that it's a secular nation
the idea of course there's the first
amendment and people must construe that
with the word separation of church and
state
we hear a lot that the founding fathers
specifically were deists they weren't
christians and it was really founded
more on enlightenment principles
um can you just as a jumping off point
let me know what's what's correct what's
incorrect there what was
the intent for the united states from
the people who who created it
well let's deal first with where they
get their ideas where they enlightenment
ideas
and in the history of the world you go
back to all the classics and all the
earlies
cato and cicero and plato and all those
guys and then you get to a period of
time where the world goes into the dark
ages
about 1300 years of illiteracy nobody's
reading nobody can read only the elites
read
books are not common for anyone then you
get to the point of what we would call
reformation and reformation
was really a bunch of christian folks
saying we got to get back to reading
which means the bible so we got to have
literacy
so that's why that those that first came
to america the pilgrims the puritans
others they were big bible guys
and america had the highest literacy
rate
of anywhere in the world at that point
including for girls we educated both
boys and girls and that wasn't being
done in europe at the time
so literacy starts coming back in really
in the 1300s 1400s 1500s
out of literacy then you get back to
what's called a renaissance
and so now you're back into art you're
inside trying to all sorts of stuff
because
for 1200 1300 years from dark ages that
stuff just wasn't doing anything
right and then out of that you get
philosophers coming out of reformation
renaissance
and that's what we call it the
enlightenment the the problem academics
have today is they separate
all the enlightenment as really an
anti-christian kind of movement of
intellectuals which is silly
um there are two strains in the
enlightenment camp
you have the secular enlightenment you
have the christian enlightenment and so
in the secular enlightenment you're
gonna have david hume you're gonna have
rousseau and voltaire you're gonna have
those guys
in the christian enlightenment you're
gonna have blackstone and montesquieu
and loch and gracias and poufendorff all
these philosophers
so when you get into that point today
they just kind of say if you're
enlightenment that's secular
that's absolute nonsense matter of fact
um i've got
all these old things i want to pull out
some things just for grants well that's
a surprise
you have a lot of old yeah surprise can
you imagine
these i mean my question is do you have
any young things out there like do you
have it like a nintendo switch
is that could it would it be too much to
add i got that from my grandkids
i got my grandkids stuff in here so i've
got that good
all right show us what you got so these
guys are
three of the enlightenment philosophers
that were the most heavily relied on by
the founding fathers
this book called the origins of american
constitutionalism
political science professors said where
the founders get their ideas they looked
at 15 000 writings from the founding era
they found all the quotes attracted back
the number one most cited source and the
founding fathers was this
the spirit of laws by montesquieu so
this guy
is a christian french philosopher the
second most cited source
was blackstone's commentaries an english
philosopher
four volume set this is one volume of it
and the third most cited source was john
locke particularly spirit of laws this
goes back to 1690.
interesting thing about john locke is
today he is considered to be
one of the deist philosophers i have
here a book from
john locke and can i clarify for the
audience really quickly a lot of people
who aren't necessarily
you know hobbyist with this the term
deist is often applied to founding
fathers to separate christians where
they say well they believed in an idea
of god but not necessarily the
judeo-christian god
um and i think that also deist has has
changed in our view of what a christian
might be today has changed so i just
want to clarify for people who may not
know because i know yeah
that's a great point diaz at the time of
the founding fathers by definition meant
someone who believed in the scriptures
believed in god
they had questions about the divinity of
jesus that's all it was that was it
adias today is one who believes in the
clockmaker philosophy
that there is a creator out there
somewhere and you wind up the universe
like the clock but he's taken off
and it just runs on its own natural law
if you pray he's not going to answer he
doesn't get involved
today if you look up the word deist in
in thesaurus or any other source you'll
find that synonyms are atheist
and agnostic right so it really has come
to be a non-god guy is really what it
was
right back at the beginning of diaz just
simply meant you believed in god jesus
the bible you just weren't sure jesus
was divine
right so it was a doctrinal issue rather
than a god issue right so great point
um this today's writers say that john
locke was a deist
that he was a secular enlightenment guy
he didn't have a great belief in god so
what i have here is a book that he did
is called the commonplace
book of the bible a little hard to see
this is
all the scriptures out of the bible the
deal with the trinity or the divinity or
i mean this is all the major doctrines
of christianity
right and it's john locke so if they say
he's a secular enlightenment guy
they're crazy because he's got writings
like this as a matter of fact this one
that i showed you
this is the most cited book by the
founding fathers when they were writing
the declaration of independence
uh one of the signers of the declaration
this guy if i can point to him right
here
this guy here is richard henry lee he's
the guy that actually made the motion
for america to become an independent
nation that's what led to the fourth of
july was his motion
right he said they copied the
declaration out of this book that was
his term
this book john locke references the
bible more than 1500 times
so when a political philosopher says oh
they quoted enlightenment philosophers
therefore they were secular
that proves to me they don't have a clue
what they're talking about they're
running on rhetoric
if anyone today if any senator
congressman or or president were to say
how many times did you say that he
referenced it 1400. if anyone were to do
that today upon swearing in they'd be
considered a radical extremist
and hauled out in cuffs so uh yeah you
know
they would be accused of establishing a
theocracy somewhere you know they're
trying to get a an ayatollah in or
something
right yeah well i don't know about the
fatwas but the principle remains
um no i understand what you're saying
and i do think that it's interesting
because
even if someone um and we'll get to that
question the divinity of christ by the
way you could refer to
all muslims as deists in that sense
because they did question the divinity
at the very least the resurrection um
that doesn't
matter so much here when we're
discussing people who were creating laws
in a system of government pragmatically
because they needed to extrapolate those
from somewhere whether they believed
that christ was resurrected and actual
god in the flesh
or not and i think people need to under
understand that because
it changes the context of the laws we
have and where they come from
well not only change the context but
even if you take those who question the
divinity of christ
out of the 56 hours of the declarations
there's really only two we know who
questioned the divinity of christ
that's franklin jefferson now here's the
deal if i go to university
duke university law school southern
university law school i'll put this
picture up and i'll always ask
who up there can you identify call my
name tell me who you got
everybody will get ben franklin
everybody get thomas jefferson there you
go
that's two out of the 56. 50 more fifty
four four five and it's easy because of
the glasses and uh
something to do with the kite it kind of
yeah
and that's a lot of fun too that's a
different story different thing
and we get into the uh the the scuba
flippers that he invented that
went with that and all the other stuff
yeah so but what you get is these two
guys are the only two to question the
divinity of christ and they're the only
two the people know today
and so they say oh well they were dis
well they were
in by definition of their day although
jefferson would
if you called him a deist he would argue
with you he called himself a christian
several occasions
franklin one time said he was a deist
and that's in his autobiography
and two pages later he says i was but
i'm not
because that he he essentially said it's
the most foolish
the most silly belief of thought out
there so within two pages he renounces
deism
but professors still quote that one
quote from franklin not paying attention
the rest that's important
for people to note and i encourage them
to read the text so let's let's do this
let's um
we'll go back to the establishment from
all of the founding fathers but let's
take those two because those come up a
whole lot you see a lot of atheists
bring up
jefferson and benjamin franklin
jefferson obviously is most cited for
you know his desire to build
people talk about a wall of separation
between the church and state
and we know about the private letter to
the danbury baptist but let's start with
what did jefferson believe what did he
want for this country the person who
people argue
he was the one who wanted no faith at
all in
any level of government so what did
jefferson believe
regarding faith the regard in america
what what aspect what he was what he
wanted to establish with the united
states
you know if it was uh because we all
know obviously it's not a religious
theocracy right it's not some kind of an
oligarch right
but then people try to say that well so
jefferson wanted didn't want anyone
praying or having any faith-based
principles
in principles involved with the founding
of government give us kind of a snapshot
as to who jefferson was
and what his vision for america was
jefferson interestingly enough when you
look at him from a faith perspective
he was raised as a very orthodox
anglican now english can be high church
that's not someone we would call an
evangelical like a franklin glare
or someone else so he's high church
which means he's much more reserved with
his expression of faith
but not necessarily his belief for
example he
is actually one of the founders of an
evangelical church
in charlottesville virginia a pastor
that was in the in the great awakening a
guy named charles clay was his pastor
personal pastor
and when charles clay got in trouble
with the british anglican church for
being too evangelical
jefferson said i'm raising money i'm
going to fund you we're going to start
you an evangelical church over here this
is where i go
and so when you look at jefferson's
relationship with pastors so many of the
evangelical pastors they were really
he was really close to people like john
leland
john leland helped do the first
amendment and he he worked with
jefferson only worked with madison on it
he worked with jefferson to disestablish
the anglican religion
so what happened is jefferson as a as an
anglican
is in a state that is an anglican state
established religion
in virginia which meant that in his
state
jefferson who's friends with all
christians jefferson is watching people
in his state like quakers
and baptists and presbyterians and
methodists be thrown in jail
be fined be whipped be beat simply
because they're not anglicans
right so jefferson hated that and so he
worked
first in 1777 right after the
declaration he introduced a bill
that would disestablish the anglican
church and say all denominations are
equal
then when he became governor he
specifically did that
he removed the professor of religion
from william and mary
and people say ah that proves he's
anti-religion now the professor of
religion william and mary was the
professor of anglican theology
william and mary and he turned william
and mary into a christian college not
at anglington college right and so
that's what jefferson's after is
free marketplace of ideas wide open for
christian faith
so jefferson actually as you go through
what he did it becomes very interesting
to see what he did before he wrote that
letter
the separation letter so in 17
in 1789 washington's president jefferson
secretary of state
congress passes a law that said hey we
told you in the constitution
find a 10 mile square piece of property
not 10 square miles but 10 miles but 10
miles by 10 miles
make that the federal city it's called
the residency act so george washington
said i know where that land is i
surveyed it
virginia and maryland will give it to
you jefferson goes there
and he lays out the federal city he gets
a french architect
pierre lanfant he gets a black surveyor
a white surveyor they lay it out
and so jefferson's in charge of building
the capital city so as they get it out
it starts construction in 1793 it's
finished in 1800
so they their first the first years in
new york city as
a federal capital then 10 years in
pennsylvania philadelphia is the federal
capital
1800 november of 1800 they moved into
the capital in washington dc
when they moved in thomas jefferson
who's been charged with this is now the
vice president united states
which means he presides over the senate
unlike mike pence today
this the vice president actually sat in
the senate every day and ran the senate
instead of mitch mcconnell or whoever
right so jefferson's in the senate and
they said now that we got this brand new
building
here's an idea the largest room in the
capitol
is the hall of the house of
representatives that's the biggest room
let's take every sunday and start a
church over
in the hall of the house and let's have
church in the u.s capitol of sunday
jefferson and speaker theodore sedgwick
do that so for the next three months
jefferson attends church every sunday in
the u.s capitol
then three months later he's elected
press in the united states
jefferson came to church every sunday in
the u.s capitol
even his political opponents who hated
him said we got to give to jefferson
he never misses church of the capital
and so when jefferson was asked by a
minister a guy named ethan allen not the
ethan allen of vermont but ethan allen
there in town he said
why do you go to church at the capitol
he said i'm the chief magistrate of a
christian nation
and that's the example you're supposed
to sit as a chief magistrate
so jefferson not only had church at the
capitol jefferson also
had church at the navy yard at the war
department and at the treasury
department
so if you want to go to church in early
washington dc you can choose four
government buildings and that's thomas
jefferson yeah
was that like mar-a-lago and trump's
golf courses he had a financial interest
in all of those churches yeah
right people in the offering plate were
none the wiser so let me before we go to
franklin then um
explain to me now when we hear that
people might be confused and say well
hold on a second what about the first
amendment and obviously jefferson is
sort of seen as
this godfather of the separation of
church and state yeah um obviously i'm
laying this up for you but i would like
for you to explain to people who may not
be familiar because most
aren't and that's what's sad they don't
learn this in school
well the very cool thing about the first
amendment is it's such simple
language and by the way separation
church and state to them and they
advocated for it
meant separation of the church from
being a state church
right they wanted church leaders to make
their own decisions uh if you're in
great britain
i mean william penn william penn spent
months in prison
for going to the wrong church the
government required him to go to an
anglican church he went to a quaker
church spent months in prison i spent
time
in the principal's office in uh grade
school because i was raised in quebec
and uh we would go to mass and it was so
i went to public school i went to
catholic school
wrap your mind around that a lot of
people don't understand it and i had
already taken communion in a
non-denominational church
uh and i didn't know that i wasn't
allowed to take communion in the
catholic church
when they found out i was immediately
sent to the principal's office and my
parents were called it was this huge
deal and uh my dad said so we go to a
church where we do communion and you
have to understand what it is he goes do
you understand what community is i say i
understand it's representation of you
know the body of christ the blood of
christ and then he sacrificed for us he
goes okay you understand that you're
praying abdominal and i said yeah he
goes okay
uh my son's free to go and uh they did
not agree so it doesn't just you don't
have to go across the pond a lot of
people don't realize
this isn't this was commonplace and so
the context of hey we don't want the
government to be enforcing
or being the church running business
rather is very different from well
of course you can pray and establish a
church in the capitol building of course
you can do that in the navy yard
so uh sorry i didn't mean to interrupt
but um no but that's good yeah that's
exactly it
and the example you gave regarding
yourself is what jefferson didn't want
right he didn't want them to come and
say you have to go to this church
and so the concept of separation church
and state is not
secularization by the way this is really
important to understand because the
critics today
say if you don't have separation church
and state the church is going to take
over the government
no no all the history of the world it's
the government who takes over the church
and makes it the arm of the state
right and so it starts back 391 a.d
emperor theodosis
said i'm a christian i now decree the
whole world is going to be christian or
i'm going to kill you that's a state
established church right
and so we have a number of documents
here from great britain time from from
the american revolution
great britain says here's who can take
communion and it's an act of parliament
great britain says hear who is licensed
to preach it's an act of parliament
parliament's got no voice over that so
jefferson does not want to secularize
the society at all right what he wants
to do is make sure the government can't
stop it so
what's really cool is when you read the
first amendment
the two religion clauses really short
congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof
key word is congress can't make a law
establishing
religion congress can't make us all
anglicans or lutherans or baptists or
catholics or quakers or atheists or
anything else
yeah in pelosi's case uh uh beelzebub
worshipers but yes go ahead
allegedly no but that that is a
important note and just an aside this is
something that a lot of people don't
understand when you
get a lot of sort of modern
intellectuals saying well it's such a
crime that uh it's
it's a crooked game a racket they say
because they're in the 1940s
that uh that churches have tax-exempt
status we need to remove well this is
exactly why because like you said
governments would go into churches
just like people are concerned about the
irs or the fbi or the doj becoming
political weapons at this point you
could do a lot of damage to by the way
any religious institution if you're
picking and choosing uh who gets tax
breaks and who don't so it's an even
playing field but
yeah so duke because that is very clear
in the first amendment
but we hear this word separation of
church and state a whole lot it's
attributed to jefferson
tell people a little bit about where
that comes from the context of his
letter to the
the danbury baptists jefferson was such
an advocate for all the other
nominations as an anglican guy
he advocated for every other
denomination that's been persecuted
and in america at the time of the
british there were nine of the 13
colonies that had a state established
religion
there was different from state to state
it might be congregationalist
it might be baptist in rhode island it
might be anglican in south carolina
so what he's what he's wanting is
freedom religious freedom
so when he got elected to office in
in 1800 and was sworn in 1801
interestingly enough he got letters just
a bunch of letters came into him as
president from baptist pastors across
the nation
because in every state except rhode
island baptists were minority pastors
and they were scared to death of the
government shut them down as they did in
virginia
and so when jefferson got in they say
hallelujah you're our guy you've been
fighting for us for years
you've got more than 15 years of
fighting for us we're so glad you're
president because we know you're going
to do the right thing and you're not
going to
punish us so one of those groups danbury
baptist association danbury
danbury connecticut wrote him a letter
it's october the 7th
1801 and they said that we are really
concerned
because this thing about congress
guaranteeing our free exercise religion
they said god guarantees our exercise
religion we think that even the word
congress appearing there might someday
cause the government to think it has a
right to regulate our religion
and so they're concerned that the words
appearing there might
think cause congress think they could
jefferson writes back
on january the 1st of 1802 it's friday
and up it's friday and there's a reason
i'll say friday
friday january first eight times he
writes back and it's a 233 word letter
it's three paragraphs long anybody can
read it in under five minutes if you're
a slow reader it'll take you under five
minutes
and jefferson said you don't have to
worry about
any government establishing or taking
over your faith
because there is a wall of separation
between church and state
that protects your religious expression
and he goes through and says because
there's a wall of separation
you're free to express your faith
however you want to anywhere you want to
any place you want
and so he gave this guarantee of
religious freedom now
what's fun is that's friday january the
1st
1802 sunday january the 3rd
1802 thomas jefferson is
in church at the capitol and the guy
who's preaching that day is the reverend
john leland who thomas jefferson
invited to come preach at the capitol of
the church so if you think separation
church and state's a bad deal what's he
doing on sunday you just violated
everything you wrote now
and this is why this is what's really
significantly steve in 1947
the u.s supreme court quoted jefferson's
letter in a case called everson versus
board of education
now what they did then was out of 233
words in the letter they only
quoted eight words a wall of separation
between church and state
every supreme court that used
jefferson's letter prior to 1947
quoted the whole letter they put it in
there and when you're ready to go this
is a no-brainer
you've got complete exercise or
religious faith we'll never stop
anything
since 1947 we have not seen a
single court reprint jefferson's full
letter
all they say is a wall of separation
there have been over 4
000 federal cases on religion since 1947
none of them caught the full letter oh
my gosh there's no space requirement and
decision you can let it go on 500 pages
you can make that a footnote right
nobody does for crying
i'll say for crying out loud i think it
was 1800 pages for brennan dassey making
a murderer so
you think they could at least shoehorn
it in there um no i think that's a it's
very interesting
and i hope that people do go and read
the letter i know i've talked about it
before but
i'm sure you probably have uh the actual
authentic copy lying around there
somewhere um
let me ask you so let's go to benjamin
franklin then since i think we've
addressed
jefferson benjamin franken franklin is
another one that people say well he was
just
he was a deist um give us a snapshot of
benjamin franklin and what his vision
for america was and who he was as a
person
yeah benjamin franklin in his own
autobiography he mentioned earlier he
said he was a deist
and he said within two pages but i found
out how silly that belief was
and i quickly rejected it in his own
autobiography he has a number
of personal psalms that he writes to god
how god answered his prayers on numerous
occasions
he talks about how important god is
throughout his life
as a matter of fact he's the guy that
brought thomas paine to america
now thomas paine genuinely is a deist
i mean he he believes in a god we
actually own a six page letter from
thomas paine
to sam adams where thomas paine's
talking about his religious faith
and what happened was except thomas
paine loved france loved the french
revolution wanted to help them get rid
of lou the 14th and all the kings
so after the american revolution he goes
to france to help them
but in the american revolution in 1772
ben franklin brought him from england to
america because he was being persecuted
in england
when he got into america he got him set
up in the printing business with a guy
named robert aiken
and in 1776 they're sitting around and
and thomas paine says i'm going to write
this piece and we now call it common
sense
but they were sitting around he and ben
franklin benjamin rush benjamin rush
is this guy right here he and ben
franklin were talking
sitting around talking about benjamin
russ says you ought to call that piece
common sense because that's what it is
common sense
so he wrote this piece common sense
washington talked about how that that
set the nation on on
edge it woke them up it's really kind of
a spark plug that set everything off
washington praised it so all the way
through the revolution thomas paine is
this great writer he does all this great
writing work
then he gets involved the french
revolution 1789.
1789 is over in france france is
absolutely hardcore secular they're
atheist secular
in france after the revolution they
actually changed the week to a 10-day
week
they didn't want a seven-day week
because that might think make you think
there's a sabbath and a god
so they changed the work week to 10 days
i mean they
tore up all the churches they second so
while he's over there he said
i saw this is painsworth i saw
france running headlong into atheism and
they didn't understand how bad that
would be for a nation
so that's why he says he wrote the age
of reason now when he wrote the age of
reason
wrote it in 1790 came out in 1794 it's a
very direct attack against christianity
it's a direct attack against judaism
but it is a defense of god and so he
said i was writing this
kind of like a step for the french to
say don't get away from god
and when it came out however because it
attacked christianity in judaism
the founding fathers turned on him and
said this is terrible
we established this nation on these
principles and now you're attacking them
what's really cool is before that and by
the way when it came out
washington would never talk to thomas
penn again after that came out
uh sam adams did an op-ed piece against
him and
boston newspapers uh patrick henry
writing and wrote an entire book trash
in thomas paine when that piece came out
i mean founding fathers turned against
him when thomas paine came back to
america and died here
there was not a single cemetery that
would let him be buried there they
buried him in a church pastor because
nobody wanted anything to do with thomas
paine
so pain is now exercised what happened
is in 1790 before payne published the
book he sent it to ben franklin
said ben you and i have been friends a
long time uh here's what i'm about to
publish
i really want to know what you think and
franklin wrote back and said
you need to burn this piece before it is
seen by
any other person he said he that spits
in the wind spits in his own face
right he said this is like unchained
entire i mean franklin
tore him up for attacking christianity
and the bible and said you do not
understand
how much we need christianity in the
bible in the nation he said think of all
the young people
whose bad behavior is restrained by the
teachings of the bible
right without this you have the law of
the tiger and sharks so so it's
it's the least religious founding father
ben franklin who tears
thomas paint up for going secular which
tells you something about franklin now
what i've got also right here and i
won't worry about pulling up
i can this is the uh this is the
original constitution for pennsylvania
1776
written by ben franklin in this
constitution ben franklin says you can't
hold office
in pennsylvania unless you believe in
the divine authority of both the
old and new testaments and believe in a
future state of rewards and punishments
and that's franklin i don't want you
close to government pennsylvania if you
don't believe the bible and believe that
you're going to stand before god and
answer for what you do
that's not a deist no way and in 1787
when franklin becomes franklin becomes
the governor
of pennsylvania as governor he actually
came up with a statewide plan to raise
church attendance in the state of
pennsylvania this is governor ben
franklin doing this was it like
like hershey's kisses or something that
was it some kind of potluck
all sorts of incentives you know he was
a coercive guy he was a free thinker he
wanted to force you into go
no i mean he was the guy that was he
wanted all these incentives for sure
right and and part of the incentive was
just intellectually don't you realize
how good religion is for a nation you
know one of the things
that um daniel webster said later daniel
webster talked
to thomas jefferson daniel webster was
the second generation of american
statesmen
and when he was a young guy he sat down
with an older thomas jefferson
and thomas jefferson this is recorded by
daniel weber thomas jefferson
told daniel webster a studious perusal
of the bible will make us
better citizens better parents better
husbands better fathers
he said you need to get in the bible
make you a better citizen so what
happened was
daniel webster turned around and said
whatever makes men good christians makes
them good citizens
and sure enough it's not the good
christians who are killing people or who
are
breaking up and looting stuff good
christians make good citizens
and that's what franklin appealed to was
hey this is great for behavior it makes
you a good neighbor makes you a nice
person to get along with
and so i mean that's franklin so
franklin and jefferson you take those
two
if that's your two least religious
founding fathers then what does that
tell you about the other guys who are
not the least religious
well that's interesting that's a good
point um i did want to ask you about
specifically you know john adams people
most people know him paul giamatti um in
1796
um he did say that the the government of
the united states is not in any sense
founded
on the christian religion and so i've
seen people argue that because
specifically
you don't see jesus or cr or
christianity
right uh mentioned or jesus let's go
specifically jesus because that's
obviously the center of this in the
constitution or declaration of
independence
that it proves uh what john adams was
saying and that's in a very limited
context that
it is in no way founded on the christian
religion because to many people they
read that quote and they say well that
seems
pretty cut and dry yeah what's wrong
with that is they're they're wrong
on that quote in so many ways that quote
is article 11 of the treaty of tripoli
the treaty of tripoli happened in the 32
years that we were having
a war on muslim terrorism quite frankly
we went from 1784 to 1816 fighting
muslim terrorists
by the time that george washington got
in office
ten percent of the federal budget was
being spent to fight muslim terrorists
and for people who don't know we did a
segment on that
in your uh in your spot there where we
went through the history of leatherneck
and uh and the navy
so that was very interesting for me i
thought they were wrist amulets because
people had very small necks back then
yeah they were well your average soldier
in the american revolution is between
five one and five four
so they were and they only ate two meals
a day gosh so they were really small
um so okay so sorry but continue the
you're mentioning that so what happens
is when we did not have a navy back then
and we could not defend we we could not
defend defeat the muslims until
thomas jefferson built john adams built
the navy thomas jefferson takes it and
says now we're going over
north africa and mediterranean we're
going to thump their heads and so that's
when they attacked
prior to that time all we could do was
negotiate with them
to not attack us and so starting in 1774
congress sent ben franklin thomas
jefferson and john adams to london to
negotiate with five
muslim ambassadors to get their nations
to stop attacking americans
and so while they were there after two
years uh jefferson has a con
jefferson records it this is in the
state department records
jefferson and john adams were still with
the muslim ambassadors the five of them
and franklin had been some
sent somewhere else so adams and
jefferson asked the muslim ambassador
said
look you trust us we trust you we don't
understand why you keep attacking
americans we've done nothing to you we
have muslims in america why are you
attacking us
and jefferson recorded it since the
state department he says
the ambassador told us it's required by
the koran
we have to your infidels we have to and
so that was like the news to them that's
when jefferson went out and bought a
quran for the first time and read it
said i can't believe you actually go to
heaven by killing people
right that was before hitchcock so it
was very scary yeah it was
yeah so with all that's gone at that
point in time
we're we're writing treaties back and
forth with the muslims how can we keep
the muslims
from attacking us because the muslims in
that period enslaved about 1.25 million
people
right captured ships men slaves
including americans and so we have these
treatises say okay
you acknowledge that we're a christian
nation we acknowledge that you're a
muslim nation and we want you to
understand we don't fight you because
you're religious we fight you because
you're terrorists
but we won't fight you because you're a
religion well the muslims said well we
fight you because you're christians
and so in in the treaties we had this
thing that says
look we'll acknowledge you're a muslim
nation you acknowledge we're a christian
nation
and that means that our embassies
can harbor the other in other words in
america if you want to send a muslim to
your ambassador
they'll be safe in america but if we
want to send a christian to our
to our embassy in in tripoli then they
need to be safe there
and so what happened was in the treaties
they acknowledged
that both nations and what they did in
the treaty of tripoli in 1797
article 11 of three tripoli says the the
government of the united states is in no
sense founded on the christian religion
period no it's not it's 82 words in that
clause
people only quote quote 17 words well
let's hear something 17 words
they put a period there it says we're
not founded on the christian religion as
having an
inherent hostility toward muslims and on
it goes
this is not the crusades we don't attack
you because you're muslim we attack you
because you're terrorists
right so it does not say the united
states is not found in the christian
religion it says we're not found in the
christian religion that you saw in the
crusades
that's not us and that's why you read
the 82 words now here's the other fun
part
the actual treaty of tripoli which is
at the national archives does not have
an article 11 in it
it doesn't even exist in the actual
treaty that clause does not even appear
it appeared in the later writings but it
does not appear in the treaty itself
try that one so why why do you think
that is so often uh
quoted and why didn't it make it into
the treaty itself
the treaty was written in arabic and
there is no article 11 there is no
clause saying that
it was translated from arabic into
italian
and from italian into english and the
guy who translated into italian
was a lousy translator and added a bunch
of stuff that wasn't in any of the
treaties
then we got translated from italian into
english
the english version translated what's in
the italian but it wasn't in the
original treaty
so what you have is in the united states
in 1797
that treaty is printed for the u.s
senate who then ratifies the treaty
so it has an article 11 in the treaty of
the united states the way the senate saw
it
but it's not in the original treaty but
the way the senate saw it had all 82
words there not just 17 words
well then and that's the difference why
didn't we go to uh war with the italians
over getting a proofreader
yeah exactly well the problem was it was
an american diplomat that did the
translation
a guy named joel barlow who was not he
didn't even speak italian
you know he thought he could never let
the italians in i don't care what rocky
marciano did
let's uh let's fast forward a little bit
because we don't we don't have a ton of
time
but um so we know that now about the
found uh the founding fathers and i
encourage everyone of course to go to
wallbuilders.com and
if you do have the time to to look up
all these artifacts it really kind of
puts things in context
but let's fast forward to you know the
pledge of allegiance because a lot of
people have a problem with that and any
mention
um of god and they say well that's not
something that is really original to
united states it was meant to
indoctrinate
uh kids and i also think there's
something that i'd like to get to you
know why americans stand
uh before the pledge of allegiance you
know hand on your heart um because
kneeling has been very popular lately
kneeling to people
which we do not have a storied history
of doing here in the united states so
first tell me about how the pledge of
allegiance came about let's start there
the pledge of allegiance came about back
in 1892 francis bellamy
he thought at a time when we heard so
many immigrants coming in we thought
this is a really good way to show our
values
and it's interesting by the way to see
there's a history of immigration that
would kind of blow people away but until
the u.s supreme court ruled in 1875 and
1876
immigration belonged totally to the
states the first time the federal
government gets involved is when the
supreme court says they can
and you don't have the first federal
immigration law until seven until 1891.
so what's happened is you have ellis
island all these folks coming in
all these immigrants coming in and the
founding fathers wrote about immigration
what she needed for good immigration
because
uh of this of the 55 55 guys who framed
the constitution seven of the guys were
immigrants we had a lot of immigrants
who actually framed the constitution
they were a nation of immigrants matter
of fact that's one of the grievances in
the declaration
is king george iii trying to shut down
our immigration
and that's a grievance against him now
the deal is
to be an immigrant back at that point in
time the states controlled it and you
had a pledge of loyalty to the beliefs
of the state the beliefs of the nation
et cetera
it wasn't just come in and be here you
got
that here's an interesting term for it
hebrew i've been involved in a lot of
hearings in congress etc
and one of the popular bible verses that
people like to use for open borders and
open immigration is leviticus 19 34
and it says the alien or the stranger
among you you used to be strangers in
egypt so you invite the stranger and
treat them the same as you would
yourself
and that's where people say hey the
bible says open immigration well
talk to a rabbi i've got a rabbi i love
him he's a great rabbi he says no no he
says
that word in hebrew says it in in
english you only have one word it's
alien or stranger he said in hebrew
we have three words that word which
doesn't translate in english well is the
word proselyte
it says if anyone comes to your nation
and wants to be a proselyte wants to
become
one of you wants to adopt your loves and
take your culture and take
he said then you treat them just like
they're a citizen well that's what we do
with immigration
right if you come in and become an
immigrant we treat you like a citizen
but you got to come here to be an
immigrant not to be illegal right if
you're a communist that's
back to ellis island or fire island
right next to judy garland slippers
yeah right there with darth vader and
everything else too yeah so that's yeah
it's very interesting that that word so
three words in hebrew
there are three words in hebrew and one
of them one of them is a natural-born
citizen one is an immigrant citizen and
one is what we would call a green card
holder they're there for a job and not
but they still have to live by the laws
of the land but they're not there to
become a citizen so
all of that to say we're in a big
immigration time in the 1860s 1870s
1880s 1890s
and francis bellamy said hey what better
thing to do than to
sit forth a belief of what we as
americans have this is something every
immigrant can learn we as americans
believe it
it helps them assimilate into the
culture and so that's what it was now
the way we got under god in it really
interesting uh when eisenhower
became president after having then all
he did in
world war one then world war ii d-day
everything he becomes uh nato commander
first nato commander
after the war he becomes president
columbia university now he's president
of the united
states he said in his inaugu he said the
night before
that he was thinking about how secular
america has become that was coming way
too secular
he was really concerned about that he
said i don't know what to do because i'm
not a preacher so i can't preach a
sermon
but as he was going to inauguration he
thought i know what i can do
i can pray and so if you look on youtube
eisenhower actually prays his own
inaugural prayer he was not on the
program he just prayed
we actually owned that original prayer
here i mean this handwritten prayer
we've got it's really cool
so he gets in and he starts the national
day of
the congressional prayer breakfast which
first thursday of every february
about 8 000 people gather from 140
nations leaders across the world
for the congressional prayer breakfast
now really quickly eisenhower did
was that uh you just mean by executive
order or kind of fill people in on that
he worked with he worked with congress
on that uh he worked to establish that
with congress
also worked with congress to get a
prayer room put in the in the
in the capital united states he also is
the guy
who said we need and god we trust in our
money all of our money
uh and he said while we're at it let's
make that the national motto
under god came about a really different
way he was attending church at new york
street presbyterian church
the pastor was a scottish immigrant had
just gotten to america from scotland
george dockery and he we actually have a
sermon you see it on the website the
sermon he preached
in 1954 he said i'm new to your country
he said but when my kids came home from
school this week he said i've been here
a few months
my kids came home from school and i said
what'd you guys do at school today
and they said well we do the same thing
we always do he said well i don't know
what american school do what did you do
i said
well we had a prayer and we had a
scripture and we said the pledge of
allegiance and we
you said the what we said the pledge of
allegiance what's that
well we pledge to the american flag the
american flag has a pledge
yes what is it and so they recited
pledge allegiance to the flag the united
states of america to the public for
which it stands
one nation indivisible with deliberating
justice for all
he says i've been thinking about that
pledge all week and now this is at the
time when the cold war is really going
hard uh we're in the vet we're in the
korean war
we've got all the communism stuff he
said i've been thinking he said that
pledge
could be said by the soviets because
they claim to be a republic with liberty
and justice for all
he said that claim could be made by the
chinese he said that claim could be made
by any nation of the world said but
america is not any nation
he said what makes america different
from all other nations is you guys have
god
you guys really ought to put under god
in your pledge of allegiance
well sitting on the front row you've got
eisenhower and senators and
representatives in church and guess what
happened on monday morning they
introduced the bill said
that's great let's put god in the pledge
because that's our core value it's what
makes us different from other nations
that's how we got under god in the
pledge now we can actually go back to
the star-spangled banner written in 1814
because the fourth stanza says and in
god is our trust so
we had under god back then that was a
state motto for states like rhode island
since way back in the 1600s
that that motto under god and god we
trust appeared on a whole bunch of stuff
before it went the pledge
so it's not a brand new innovation but
the way it came about it's kind of a fun
story
that is yeah and it's interesting that
we don't have uh we don't have uh that
uh in the american national anthem but
they do say uh
uh god uh keep our land in canada you
know between uh
between blackface um so let me ask this
the uh
kneeling has been a big thing with the
flag right with the national anthem
um we stand and i think that's a
contrast that people
maybe miss why do we stand at the pledge
of allegiance let me ask you this first
kind of going back so i know we're doing
a little bit of looper here
um were the founding fathers did they
ever or is there a historical precedent
where they would kneel
for other men particularly other men
ruling over them
they would kneel for god right and they
would kneel in church
other than that you're not going to find
them kneeling you'll find washington
kneeling and prayer
valley forge and as an anglican he
usually stood when he prayed
that's like sackcloth and ashes when an
anglican meals that's that's big stuff
for washington neal uh but no we didn't
kneel to men
and that was a big deal they're not
going to deal with king george iii
statues came down that that indicated
any kind of subservient we
were not serviced to anybody we stood
our own two feet
right so there was nothing kneeling and
that's interesting symbolism to me
because
um and obviously people will bring up
slavery and the injustices and we've
done an entire segment on that i
encourage people to go
to go watch it even the idea of the old
party switch i think we've done a
segment on that
but anyone who is at a football game or
anyone any of these protests who
says we're kneeling and protesting the
flag i don't think they understand
the context in that that was a conscious
decision
the founding fathers to not kneel before
any man but only to god
and when you are standing at the pledge
of allegiance that's saying that as
americans
we are not subservient to any other man
the president
or king george and i think it's an irony
that's lost on people the standing
is already a figure to flip the bird to
some kind of authoritarian figure
and kneeling is going back to what we
left
yeah it is it's going the wrong
direction you know it's designed to show
some disrespect
but and this is a little sidebar off the
side
so many of the guys who actually
suffered racial injustice at the level
that we'll never know
actually suffered the impression
actually suffered slavery
actually were persecuted and beat
because they were just black
guys like that that fought in the civil
war
folks don't understand that seven black
patriots got the medal of honor
for not allowing the american flag to be
disrespected they were so
loyal to the flag because it was the
other flag that they didn't like it
wasn't the american flag that's the one
that brought all the liberty
it's the other flag that they had
trouble with and so
the quotes by black soldiers in the
civil war
and their absolute admiration for the
flag that that's what gave them hope and
optimism
it's the other flag that was the
oppression of slavery you know
confederate flag or whatever you want to
say
so these guys i'm to have medal of honor
winners
if you watch the movie glory but if you
read the real story he got shot four
times
because he would not let the flag touch
the ground be disrespected that was four
shots
right and and so i don't think we
understand history even in the racial
sense
of where the respect for the flag was
the early congressman
uh the first the first 13 congressmen
seven of them had been slaves five years
before
right what has changed to be a slave and
five years later you're sitting in
congress sure
and no one's saying that it's not and no
one's saying that we're a perfect nation
and with a perfect history of course
because
we've we've uh talked about that at
great length in the past and i encourage
people to go watch it but
we stood so that uh we stood and it took
us a little while that everybody
could stand figuratively here's the
sites we ended slavery but we keep in
mind if we hadn't stood
at all everyone black white red yellow
would still be kneeling
and uh i think i think we can leave it
on that wallbuilders.com
mr barton thank you so much for taking
the time i always learn something and by
something i mean uh a lot because i know
very little
thank you sir uh we appreciate it we
hope that you'll be back soon
thanks brother have a happy end penn
state absolutely everyone else too
uh i think we're supposed to say fourth
because independence a little iffy we'll
see you soon
[Music]